the national lead NFL writer bleacher
report Mike Freeman right you're a data
guy right Mike well it's it's data and I
got a thing to say to you rich first of
all my first point you're running a four
five eight when okay when I need like I
need you on the on the on the stopwatch
instead of May otic
yes sir the most disrespectful move of
all time was it Jordan or Scottie Pippen
who don't own Ewing
it was Pippen but Jordan Jordan but the
harden move last night reminded me of
Jordan on on Brian Russell back in the
day that's a good one but when you dunk
on someone and then you step over them
like that's just really disrespectful
yeah I guess we didn't even include
Allen Iverson on tyloo I guess we didn't
include that step stepping over somebody
that's big
you only included I guess hurtling
people so let me let me start with you
here because you've been writing about
this quite a bit lately what is going on
with the Cowboys and Dez Bryant there's
a there there and I don't know what the
bear there is gonna actually wind up
being over there what can you tell me I
happen well I have to be completely
honest I don't I don't know exactly and
I don't know if the Cowboys know it's
there's definitely something there as
you said I don't know if I would call it
tension I don't know what its what it is
but there's Dez the Cowboys aren't as
excited about bringing him back and the
what I wrote recently was my point was
more that he still has something left
even though there's a lot of people in
the league who don't think he does I'm
in the minority there's a lot of people
in the league who think he's completely
lost it he's lost a step he's a second
guy he's not I think you underestimate
him at at your own peril and maybe the
car
of doing that I think the Cowboys are in
a position where they love him they want
they would want him back but at the
right price what price do you bring him
back and that's sort of where they're at
now and we could go either way I mean it
could easily get done or get easily I
could part ways dad's gonna end up
somewhere on something next year but
there's that there's a whole thought
process Richard drop the league about
where exactly he is and most people I
talk to don't think he's that guy
anymore
but I still think it can be so that's
where kind of things are with that right
well the problem is that you say at what
price his price is the one then he's
under contract for that's the way it
sounds like he's gonna approach this
thing and and the question is is when
the rubber meets the road which is the
moment the Joneses really put a number
on the table saying this is what it will
take for you to stay here des that and
how he takes that that is the conundrum
here when it all comes down to it yeah
you said it exactly right and where do
you go through the Cowboys I think they
feel really good about and they should
about their team about how they draft
now about that part of their game which
to me like five years ago free agency
draft they weren't that great at it I
think now they're really good at it
and they have the quarterback they want
they think they can get that defense
where it is and they think they can be
good with DES or without this and that's
a big part of this equation is that they
feel like they can move on reaches Super
Bowl because because they got dak and
they have Zeke and they have these guys
that can step up and do good things so
that's kind of their mindset and Dez's
mindset is I'm still Dez Bryant I'm
still great with me or not with me but
I'm still great and that's where you hit
it perfectly about where this is going
to fall in when the Cowboys say we're
going here and that's as we go here do
they work it out it's still possible
they work it out Mike
Freeman and bleacher report joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show so what
happened with Marcus Peters in Kansas
City the best you can tell I think they
just I think they just sort of got tired
of one another which is weird for God
who's his youngest he is I think he's 24
he got in he got into a couple of things
with the one of the assistant coaches he
had the outburst where he tossed the
flag into the stands or kicked into the
stands and I think there was just a sort
of mutual decision to part ways I think
which I'm now you feel to me he is a
complete total baller I mean he is one
of the best he's a top five physical
athlete in his league a top three to
five corner he takes risk he's got some
some maturing to do but when I was 24 I
have a journey to do I'm attorney to do
now so everyone has to do but I think I
think the Rams got a total steal with
him and a defense that was already
really good is now just going to be even
better so I think it was just a sort of
a mutual party in the ways and those
teams just gonna move on
well I want to ask you about the
hush-hush rumor about this is that
essentially Clark Hunt did not like that
Marcus Peters did anything during a
national anthem this year any and it
just doesn't matter how much maturing
needs to be done he's out he's there any
truth to that I haven't I've heard that
saying rumor I can't get anyone to say
that that's accurate
it would not shock me there's you and I
talked about the end the anthem before
and the protest before and and how
players feel about it and how we feel
about it
it was a huge factor for a lot of teams
and it wouldn't shock me if that was the
case there I mean it was a factor for a
lot of owners for a lot of teams I'll go
back to what I said before I don't know
why it's it's peaceful protests are
doing what you're allowed to do what you
should do to me
but there were a lot of people didn't
like it so I haven't necessarily heard
any confirmation of that but I've heard
it
but wouldn't shock me it was a such a
polarizing issue unnecessarily so to me
but it was in the league and it was
everywhere
so wouldn't stun me but they definitely
to me let him go
considering his talent and how good he
is on the cheap to me so it would not
shock me about there was some accuracy
to that but I just happened to her and
what's going on with Colin Kaepernick's
suit against the NFL
it's what what what's the status on that
and and is there any chance that
Kaepernick should should somehow someway
the political environment change does he
does he want to play in the NFL still do
you think he still want yeah I think
Richie still wants to play definitely I
don't I my contention has been for a
long time now that he he won't play an
NFL again and I don't think he will I
think he he wants to and his his case
against the league is just it's just
turn along it's just going and and it's
been very quiet there have been perfect
leagues and I think it's because they
just especially some call inside they
just want to make sure they that they
just present their best case and just do
that but it's he wants to play again and
he in but I don't think you will rich I
think it's I think it's playing Dave
enough and the NFL are done pretty much
no matter what happens with this case
which is unfortunate because he's still
a really really fantastic player and I
think the NFL overall needs some these
guys like him he's an exemplary person
so the lis can always use people who
good people like that on the field who
are also excellent and ambassadors off
the field as polarizing you some people
all he is done is give his life to
people underprivileged people people of
color all over the countries raised
millions and charity
he is a example of what you wanted an
NFL player but I don't think the league
is gonna let him play that's been my
feeling for a long time Mike always
appreciate the time appreciate the call
and more importantly my gosh appreciate
you think I'm going sub 5 whatever
you're having I'll have to okay four
four five nine baby okay you take care
of yourself Mike thank you that's Mike
Freeman the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience